[Applause]
adams trying to sneak it back door
wouldn't happen green pushing dishing
thompson
hit it from but we have seen how they
play in his absence
thompson a deep one
he's good
about that hey if adams is going to
completely sag off you you need to shoot
thompson shooting
his third three in the court
[Music]
here's thompson clark hanging thompson
hitting
eliza keeps it alive for thompson connex
for three of game six for clay thompson
we already know there will be two game
sevens will there be a third memphis
trying to force one thompson you bet
five for five for clay thompson jones
cold tonight now one for six from the
floor
green to the corner thompson
[Music]
and that's the basketball that they need
to play
[Applause]
thompson
again
warriors still trying to push that pace
thompson will pull up from two and
connect
clay is on a burner and clay's been
doing it all look using his body get to
his little mini right now golden state
with a three-point lead
a lot of high percentage looks last few
possessions for both teams
thompson all the way in
loony
he needs help finds green curry has to
pull
can't hit looney another board
he's got 20 thompson puts it in and that
might be the dagger
set up klay thompson for this
ladies and gentlemen
if you didn't know him let me
re-introduce you to mr clay thompson
also known as game six clay